Hey, David, when will you start going to restaurants,
the gym, the movies, traveling and doing all
of your normal life after a Corona virus?
I don't know.
I've been thinking about this a lot.
Talking to friends and family.
And I'm planning to get an antibody test next
week or the week after.
And it's conceivable that my behavior may
be different if it turns out that I already
had the virus.
I think that that might affect my behavior
to some degree.
But I'm not just thinking about myself.
I'm thinking about do I want to be seeing
my parents when they start dying down?
Because if so, I probably need to do the responsible
thing and not go to some of these places,
particularly if I don't have the antibodies,
if I want to be around my parents.
So I think for me, the gym seems pretty far
off.
That seems like a cesspool of germs and contagion.
I never go to the movies as it is.
The last movie I saw was not the latest Star
Wars, but the previous one is the last time
I went to the movies.
I think that was three or four years ago here
in Boston.
So I think I'm fine without going to the movies.
I don't really care about the movies.
For me, the big things really are seeing friends,
particularly at beer gardens or going to restaurants,
going to cafes, etc..
I'm feeling like if they are going to start
opening some of those up with reduced capacity,
my favorite cafe said we're going to operate
at 20 percent capacity and the employees will
wear masks.
And you know, it's kind of hard to have a
mask on when when you're eating or drinking,
but I would probably go and sit with my laptop.
If the numbers keep declining in Massachusetts
the way they have been, if in three weeks
those places start to open, I'd probably go
and sit with my laptop for two hours, have
a coffee, then come home, wash my hands.
And I think I would be comfortable with that.
Travel is a real question mark.
I don't know.
I had a bunch of trips canceled, including
I was supposed to be in L.A. on the Joe Rogan
program last week and try I had vacations
planned.
I don't know when that's going to resume,
but I will probably just look at, you know,
when when we travels down air travels down
95 percent.
My senses where I'm not gonna be the first
person to get back on a plane when I see the
numbers recovering.
Particularly evaluating the case cases in
Massachusetts and where I would be flying
to all kind of make that call when it comes
to it.
I would love to be able to go somewhere in
August at this point.
I don't know if we'll still be in wave one
or maybe already in wave two.
Or maybe things would be OK to travel.
I don't know.
But I'm not making any any sort of bigger
decisions about that right now.
Curious to hear where your mind is.
I know I have.
I have friends who have been traveling throughout
and I have friends who are saying they're
not traveling until 2022 or going to restaurants,
period, for any time in the foreseeable future.
I guess I'm kind of in the middle and I'm
going to make decisions on on a case by case
basis.
Right now, I'm looking to May 18 to see how
much two cases hopefully keep declining in
Massachusetts.
And will our governor, Charlie Baker, open
anything up on that date?
Let me know your thoughts.
We've got a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Get instant access to the bonus show two ways.
These are quick.
You go to join Packman dot com and just sign
up the coupon code.
20-20 now saves you 66 percent if you want
it.
Sign up in under a minute.
Get the bonus show or become a patron at Patry
on dot.com slash.
David Pakman show also takes under a minute.
Gets you instant access to the bonus show.
We'll see you then or on Monday.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.